pourquoi si j'aime bien de pente et
geneviève de fontenay lé là messieurs
standing ovation comme d'habitude
évidemment comment ça marche et n'diaye
bah quand je te vois très bien
je ne vais chanter l'amour tous les deux
ans les bras ton chapeau quand même ça
c'est une affaire privée mais qu'est ce
qu'il y a geneviève sous son chapeau
oh
eh bien geneviève de fontenay bonsoir
gad elmaleh jetons avec jean paul rouve
santé voilà j'ai croisé des gens mais on
se rend compte
ça c'est fait c'est fait je vous mets
sur des coulées mais câble alors j'aime
bien différent ça commence je ne sais
pas sans fin parce qu'on va
s'embrouiller avec j'aime bien vaut
mieux que ça commence ce soir geneviève
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle pour vous exprimer
après l'événement qui a marqué cette
semaine incroyable
jeudi nous avons appris que geneviève de
fontenay avait vendu bien saviez ça fait
déjà plusieurs années qu'il est en
rapport avec endemol qu'arthur week-end
non partir ne peuvent pas spécialement
les hollandais directement elle est
correctement se sont aperçus que
l'élection de miss france
n'en déplaise à certains qui commença à
dire ses terres à garder mode et ça
valait plus rien miss france sont rendu
compte quand même qu'avec l'audimat 10
millions de cette réunion ses 12 par les
années où sur la malle oui oui voilà
c'était quand même ça représentait
quelque chose donc quelque part c'est
l'aboutissement quand même d'années et
d'années pour enfin que moi j'ai ramé
quand même pendant un certain temps
ça prouve quand même qu'on a mené miss
france au top que ça représente un
événement non vérifiés pour le vendre
mais comme vous l'avez vendus ou non
c'est la société miss france nue devant
lui et moi je reste la présidente du
comité miss oise
jusqu'à ma mort ah bon on a dit qu'est
ce que deviendra après vous by rapide
committee ah bon d'accord avant d'accord
alors j'espère société miss france est
vendu à endemol
voilà bien vous avez vendu je sais pas
non non je sais pas je ne sais pas une
femme d'affaires moi je fais le chiffre
d'affaires la société chaque année j
d'affaires est de 4 millions vous avez
vendu sa 50 60 millions 10 et c'est
énorme
il est trop bien arthur pour lui c'est
une semaine devant moi je continue mon
petit train train alors je ne vous
inquiétez pas je suis pas encore parti
et je dois dire que vous aviez à
convaincre c'est un coup de maître
parce que quand il a mené non il a mené
sa demande m
tf1 était sur le coup ben hatira et on a
un contrat de deux ans encore avec eux
sur le coup pour racheter la wii mais je
tenais je pense donc pas été assez fort
joe papp il assez de pognon ça a donné
ça va lui faire tout drôle
à l aller vers ça se voit à 10 ans il va
alors vous donc vous êtes vous algériens
allaient bien dangereux
le coran
plaidant coupable un doux comme un
agneau les biens alors vous donc vous
allez la tournée qui a thani est trop
fort franchement respect
ouais ouais
d'habitude c'est mieux les enfants un
mac os et d'entravé donc je vais toucher
le magot j'aime bien être clairement
pour l'instant j'ai connu on s'éclaire 1
et 2 ans que j'aurais j'ai déjà donné
une petite fille et puis surtout vous
pourrez filer du pognon à arlette
laguiller à m